spécial européenne à 20h30 jacques
chirac et jean trajet réponses aux
questions d'antenne 2 et europe par les
massacres en centrafrique la france
suspend son aide militaire à l' empire
de bokassa élections canadiennes le
conservateur jim clark l'emportent sur
pierre elliott trudeau
mais à messieurs bonsoir c'est d'abord
par les suites judiciaires des incidents
du 23 mars à paris que nous allons
commencer ce journal nous vous l'avions
promis lundi
nous avons décidé d'ouvrir plus
largement ce dossier très contesté qui a
fait douter de leur justice une partie
des français
et rien que ceux ci méritait qu'on prête
attention aux problèmes
aujourd'hui en effet la 10e chambre de
la cour d'appel de paris examiné le cas
de trois manifestants interpellés lors
des fameux événements de la place de
l'opéra
deux d'entre eux avaient été condamnés
en première instance à d'assez lourdes
peines le dernier avait été relaxé mais
le parquet avait fait appel
ces jugements à l'instant en appel ont
été très peu modifiée
les premier jugement avait provoqué
l'émotion d'une partie de la classe
politique et de la presse il faut dire
que les témoignages recueillis quant aux
faits n'étaient pas toujours très
convaincant regardez plutôt les
résultats d'une enquête que nous avons
menée sur le cas de deux manifestants
enquête réalisée hier soir à l'occasion
d'une manifestation de soutien
pierre le gall aides soignants dans un
service d'enfants 18 mois de prison dont
10 avec sursis
accusé d'avoir lancé des pierres contre
des policiers qu'il n'y avait rien dans
les mains comme ça ils n'avaient pas de
renflouement suspecte n'est pas de barre
de fer n'avait rien du tout quand les
crs ont commencé à charger
vous savez
nous sommes rabattus sur le golan et
italiens
et à partir de ce moment là nous avons
commencé à courir claire était en amour
il est tombé
on me retournant j'ai vu que les crs
étaient sur lui en train de le en train
de les matraquer
une manière qui leur est tout à fait
particulière fondamentalement c'est un
non violent
la preuve d'ailleurs c'est que il a
demandé à être objecteurs de conscience
face et c'est vraiment un doux 1
pacifiques et non violents alors tout le
monde peut changer brusquement plus
brusquement se mettre à leur compte et
crs mais c'est pour le moins extrêmement
étonnant le 23 mars dernier philippe
duval est arrêtée vers 19h30 les
policiers en civil affirme l'avoir
distinctement vu dans la manifestation
je t'ai de la main droite un cocktail
molotov qui a incendié une banque
incendie maîtrisé par les pompiers mais
philippe duval est gaucher il y à
confusion sur le nom et l'adresse de la
banque et les pompiers ne sont jamais
intervenus
il ya confusion également sur les
horaires sévèrement le carl frega
s'associent
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment là on est allé en marchant
jusqu'à la place de l'opéra et là on a
vu qu'il y avait
c'est le cas c'est y ait beaucoup de
gens y ait encore des odeurs de bombes
lacrymogènes puis on a dû se perdre avec
philippe un petit peu une demi-heure
après qu'ils ont été trop lents 6h15 je
pense
il était environ 17h45 et l'engin a été
jeté d'un petit groupe qui se trouvait
derrière nous au niveau du kiosque qui
se trouve là sur la place ce qui est
curieux c'est que on a dit dans la
presse que
les policiers avaient d'abord vu le
lancer du cocktail molotov contre la
banque et de la ottomane qui se trouvent
de l'autre côté en face et dont
l'apparence est totalement incompatible
avec celle de la banshee d'amyris sans
vous donc une adresse en france
à oui je dis qu'il ya une
invraisemblance ci après les témoignages
de la police ont été différence et c'est
un autre problème mais il ya total
invraisemblances je crois que le grave
de cette histoire c'est que on est en
train de juger d'une manière telle sans
instruction en refusant le complément
d'enquêté que les défenseurs ont demandé
sans ouvrir les dossiers avec une
rapidité telle qu'il n'est pas possible
d'apporter une preuve quelconque d'un
examen de dossier et donc de culpabilité
de non culpabilité
alors bien sûr devant la gravité des
accusations nous nous sommes en tournée
vers le procureur de la république qui
évidemment n'a pas voulu juger le
jugement mais qui s'élève avec force
contre cette campagne de remise en cause
des décisions des magistrats nous
l'écoutons c'est au juge saisi dans ces
conditions qu'il appartient d'apprécier
si dans le dossier qu'il vit soumis les
éléments qui lui sont apportés sont tous
nous suffisant mais ce choix de la
procédure est fait en toute indépendance
le choix est fait parce que les
conditions de cette procédure sont
remplies et il y à tous les jours ce
indépendamment de la volonté peut-être
politique de faire un exemple mais il
est certain que cette procédure est une
procédure qui a le mérite dans la
saisine du tribunal de la rapidité et
qui est une procédure qui se fait à
chaud mais elle se fait dans tous types
de délits qui remplissent les conditions
pour l'appliquer il n'y a donc rien de
politique dans le choix de cette
procédure pour tel ou tel type
d'infractions telles celles auxquelles
vous pensez
et si le juge estime que le dossier est
suffisant que les témoins sont
suffisantes et que leur déclaration
entraîne sa conviction à lui juge
eh bien il statue il condamne et il
prononce une peine sans avoir la volonté
toute simple de faire un exemple
il y a toujours un effet d'exemplarité
dans une sentence pénale c'est un des
effets de la peine en toute matière
l'effet dissuasif et les faits d'
exemplarité existe indiscutablement dans
la sanction pénale
jean françois kahn les magistrats
s'indignent les hommes politiques
s'étonne pourquoi ce malaise oui parce
que a priori boher appelé fait que
manifestations de la cgt pacifique
effectivement des autonomes des casseurs
le 23 mars qui la détourne de son objet
et kick-ass qui se livrent à des
violences à des déprédations
c'est vrai et l'opinion publique
rappelez vous le lendemain qui s'indigne
la presse qui qui protestent bien alors
la justice juge rapidement et sévèrement
elle frappe c'est au fond ce que le
monde et l'opinion alors pourquoi ce
malaise alors je veux dire pourquoi
semaine me semble-t-il parce que au fond
on a eu l'impression impression quand on
a commencé à juger ces jeunes gens que
c'était moins des casseurs finalement ou
de vrais autonome que l'on jugeait que
peut-être les gens que l'on n'avait pris
que l'on avait pris parce qu'il ne
courait pas assez vite au fond je pense
justement à ce jeune homme qui avait des
sabots c'est vrai on a pu vérifier ou
cet autre jeune homme qui était au
cinéma une heure avant et qui est sortie
avec des grenades lacrymogènes ont été
obligés d'évacuer la salle donc il
n'avait pas prévu d'être là alors il ya
au moins si vous voulez pour certains un
doute et on a eu l'impression que ce
doute n'aurait pas bénéficié vraiment
alors vous me direz c'est vrai que
quelquefois l'opinion publique
s'indigne devant des fêtes ce qui s'est
passé et dit c'est plus possible ça peut
pas continuer et nous mêmes nous
réagissons comme ça souvent dans notre
for intérieur il faut sévir pour
l'exemple mais justement la grandeur
l'honneur de notre justice de la justice
d'un pays démocratique c'est quand même
elle n'a pas à juger par indignation
elle n'a pas jugé pour l'exemple elle
doit juger des délits précis et certains
à tort ou à raison se sont demandés si
cette fois elle n'avait pas dix en vue
j'ai plus émotivement que sereinement
voilà le problème
j'ajoute qu'à briller cette fois hélas
sans aucun rapport avec le jugement de
paris les cinq manifestants arrêtés en
flagrant délit la nuit du 17 au 18 mai
c'est à dire pendant les derniers
affrontements ont été eux relaxé
par ailleurs georges séguy a écrit cet
après midi au premier ministre pour lui
demander de retirer d'urgence les forces
de police de longwy de briller qui sont
ils responsables de l'aggravation de la
tension
ça m'arrive maintenant aux conséquences
diplomatiques du massacre des écoliers
de bangui s'il fallait s'y attendre la
france a décidé de suspendre son
programme d'eads militaire à l' empire
centrafricain jusqu'à ce que le rapport
de la commission africaine créée par le
sommet de kelly soit rendue publique
monsieur léger salue la décision des
états africains de procéder à une
enquête sur place
et de confier celle ci à des
personnalités donnent la part leurs
compétences et parlant expérience toute
garantie d'objectivité d'impartialité on
ne comprendrait pas que la france dont
le principe est que les africains
doivent régler eux mêmes dans tous les
domaines les problèmes qui sont les
leurs se substitue au jugement d'une
commission constituée par des
représentants d'état respecté en afrique
et dans le monde
jean françois poncet répondait à deux
députés socialistes et communistes
messieurs mexandeau et léger il s'agit
donc je le répète de l'aide militaire
française qui n'est guère importante
en revanche l'aide civile elle
représente pour l' empire centrafricain
une partie très importante de son budget
l'armée centrafricaine et la garde
impériale ça n'est pas plus de trois
mille hommes il n'existe plus
officiellement aujourd'hui deux
conseillers français et l'aide militaire
de paris a diminué au fil des années
en revanche plusieurs dizaines
d'officiers centrafricains sont formés
en france mais le pays de bokassa et là
des rares pays d'afrique qui n'est
jamais dénoncer les accords de défense
avec paris autrement dit en cas
d'agression contre le régime
la france peut voler au secours de
lempire centrafricain comme elle l'a
fait deux fois pour l'oeil depuis le
scandale du massacre des enfants de ben
10 l'aide militaire et donc suspendu
cette sanction apparaît la seule
possible comment en effet punir le
dictateur sans pénaliser aussi 3
millions de centrafricains comme ce que
vous allez voir qu'ils travaillent
parfois pour une bouchée de pain dans la
recherche du diamant l'aide officielle
de la france représente le tiers du
budget centrafricain 150 millions de
nouveaux francs le prix d'un airbus
c'est peu mais paris vient d'effacer
oscille ardoise de dettes de l' empire
et la plus grande partie de son budget
dépend de toute façon de l'aide
extérieure
la france coopèrent surtout dans le
domaine de l'agriculture l'exploitation
de forêts construction de route pour
tenter de désenclaver ce pays qui ne
possède aucun débouché sur la mer 400
coopérants français travaillent ici en
république centrafricaine nous achetons
aux centrafricains du bois du café et du
tabac nous sommes et de loin leur
premier partenaire boycotter lempire
centrafricain équivaudrait à couler
l'économie de ce pays où le revenu par
tête d'habitant ne dépasse pas 300
francs pressions et menaces gel des
accords militaires sont finalement les
seules armes de paris contre le régime
de bokassa 1er
alors cette parenthèse refermée voyons
un peu comment les autres chefs d'état
africains ont ressenti cette mise au ban
de la société de l'un des leurs ils
étaient vous savez réunis pendant deux
jours à kigali au rwanda
mon adversaire vous avez vécu parmi eux
prendre deux jours bien en l'occurrence
et africains sont très embarrassés pour
la non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures d'un autre état est quelque
chose de capital peut-être parce qu'ils
tiennent absolument à ce qu'on respecte
leur indépendance et leur souveraineté
nationale qui ne sont pas tellement
ancienne du coup ils hésitent à porter
un jugement sur un autre état africain
même si les dirigeants de cet état
africains ne sont pas sans reproche et
dans le cas du centrafrique
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire est ce
que cela suffit à expliquer que lorsque
samedi après midi plus tôt dimanche
après midi à l'aérodrome de kigali
lorsqu'on annonce et l'avion de bokassa
la foule a applaudi comme les autres
états africains
est-ce que ça suffit a expliqué qu'on
lui a apporté des fleurs non ça c'était
peut-être parce qu'ils allaient est cuit
son épouse l'impératrice catherine d'un
charmant améris catherine choisi les
africains sont d'autant plus gêné que
bokassa a eu l'habileté de demander lui
même on envoie en centrafrique
vingt huit missions cette mission d'
enquête où cette commission denquête
alors au total les abris les africains
cette fois ci sont vraiment très
malheureux parce que après amin dada il
ya maintenant bokassa et un africain
particuliers montrent estimable s'agit
de l'ambassadeur du sénégal à paris me
disais que cela un très très mauvais
effet sur la bonne renommée du continent
africain avec eux valéry giscard
d'estaing lui a quitté kigali pour
le soudan il est arrivé tout à l'heure
au soudan il va y rencontrer monsieur
unis mary qui est président en exercice
de l'ua l'organisation de l'unité
africaine et le programme huit
françaises y voit comme un terreau est
numéro 1 que le président en exercice de
la communauté européenne c'est lui
rencontre donc le président de l'ogc à
l'étranger toujours la défaite de pierre
elliott trudeau aux élections
canadiennes après onze années de
présence à la tête du gouvernement
fédéral il doit donc céder la place aux
conservateurs c'est une formation
dirigée par monsieur joe clark 40 ans le
plus jeune premier ministre ait jamais
connu le canada c'est un pierre elliott
trudeau assez émue qui s'est tout à leur
adresse et vous le verrez aux
journalistes il a la larme à l'oeil
malgré une assistance fanatiques
je ferai at il dit avec assez d'humour
britannique
je ferai un très bon leader de
l'opposition avec luc chatenet
maintenant le portrait de l'ancien et du
nouvel homme fort canadien premier
ministre depuis 11 ans pierre elliott
trudeau et son parti libéral sont donc
les grands perdants de ces élections
non seulement les libéraux ont perdu
leur majorité absolue au parlement mais
surtout ils ont connu une véritable
déroute dans l'ouest du canada à forte
domination anglophone désormais plus
aucun parti canadien ne peut se targuer
d'une implantation solide à l'échelle du
pays tout entier
à cet égard les chèques des libéraux est
surtout un échec personnel pour trudeau
qui avait axé toute sa campagne sur le
maintien de l'unité du canada qu'il
prétendait incarner mieux que quiconque
son vainqueur le voici joe clark 39 ans
il sera le plus jeune premier ministre
de l'histoire du canada sa victoire
n'est pourtant pas complète en effet son
parti progressiste conservateur ne
dispose pas de la majorité absolue et
devra donc se ménager des appuis auprès
des petits partis joe clark araxxe est
très axé l'essentiel de sa campagne sur
les thèmes économiques lutte contre
l'inflation et le chômage et sur une
réduction de la bureaucratie fédérale
pour ce qui est des problèmes du québec
monsieur clark a tenu dès son élection à
rassurer les francophones
mon gouvernement at il dit sera vraiment
nationale est représentatif
et je désirais faire entrer des
québécois il a annoncé qu'il réunirait
une conférence pour étudier de nouveaux
rapports entre le pouvoir fédéral et les
provinces
reste à savoir si le nouveau premier
ministre pourra résister tant aux
pressions de son électorat anglophone co
velléités autonomistes de rené lévesque
et du parti québécois changement d'homme
également aujourd'hui chez nos voisins
allemands
l'enjeu était de moindre importance mais
il s'agissait quand même de donner un
successeur à valter shell jusqu alors
président de la république ce avec la
base ce poste est assez honorifique
c'est un démocrate chrétien qui lui
succède helmut schmidt et lui a social
démocrate
le nouveau président s'appelle donc
carcasse sa personnalité son passé son
passé controversé
davantage en tout cas que celle de
monsieur chez
mickael président de charme et chanteur
du hit pas de politique et musicale
quitte sa fonction sûr de ne pouvoir
fixer une majorité sur son nom
il ne s'est pas représenté à ces
élections au chanteur et aux charmeurs
succède donc un président à la mine plus
austère un homme du nord analytique est
un peu rigide remplace un rhénan jovial
et bon enfant
carstens a derrière lui une carrière de
juriste et de fonctionnaires qu'il doit
largement à l'ancien chancelier konrad
adenauer une figure parmi les têtes de
file de la chrétienne démocratie
l'opposition au gouvernement de helmut
schmidt
c'est dire si la cohabitation ne sera
pas aisée entre un président allemand du
type quatrième république française
quant au pouvoir et le gouvernement de
bonn d'autant que kara carstens jadis
membre du parti national socialiste
n'est pas accepté par de larges franges
de la population allemande des
manifestation illustrait dès aujourd'hui
une certaine allergie des jeunes un
président venu d'une génération de plus
en plus remis en cause politiquement car
carstens est en effet plutôt
conservateur il n'en est pas moins très
pro-européens et francophones il est en
effet très longtemps étudié en france
nous les allemands croyons que l'europe
devrait jouer un plus grand rôle dans la
politique mondiale et pour jouer un plus
grand rôle
il faut qu'elle parle avec une seule
voix et pour parler avec une seule voix
elle doit se réunifier et c'est la
raison c'est une autre raison très forte
et la dernière raison je crois c'est une
raison économique
nous avons déjà fait l'expérience cas
avec le marché commun un développement
favorable économique a eu lieu dans tous
les pays et dans tous nos pays et je
croise ça va continuer si nous
continuons sur la voie de l'unification
de l'europe
salvador assassiné ce matin du ministre
de l'éducation par un commando de ses
forces populaires de libération qui
détiennent toujours vous le savez en
otages depuis plus de deux semaines
l'ambassadeur français proche orient
bombardements israéliens au liban tout à
l'heure l'aviation de tel aviv qui s'en
prendre à des concentrations de fedayins
dans le sud du pays et ce alors que à el
arish morcheeba gagnent le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères
rencontrait son équivalent égyptien à
gauche de l'écran boutros ghali el arish
qui doit après demain redevenir
égyptienne mais personne ne pavoise à
titre d'exemple la frontière entre
israël et le sinaï ne sera pas ouverte
comme on l'avait dit la semaine
prochaine
j'arrive maintenant à la campagne pour
les élections européennes campagne en
france campagne marquée tout d'abord
parler suite du dépôt de la liste jean
jacques servan shreiber
aujourd'hui le bureau du parti dont il
est le président du parti radical s'est
réuni sans lui et a condamné assez
sévèrement les initiatives de son leader
la liste que conduit jean-jacques
servan-schreiber ne peut en aucun cas se
réclamer du parti radical ni l'engager
en conséquence jean-jacques
servan-schreiber ne se trouve pas
actuellement en mesure d'exercer ses
fonctions de président du parti radical
le parti radical socialiste confirme son
soutien sans équivoque à la liste union
pour la france en europe
conduite par madame simone veil et sur
laquelle figure ces candidats
régulièrement investi ces candidats font
campagne sur le message du parti radical
le plein emploi par l'euro réponse de
monsieur s'arrange traverse bureau n'a
pas de pouvoir du côté de l'opposition
suite de la polémique pc ps aujourd'hui
une réponse de françois mitterrand et
georges marchais qui avait dit de lui
que c'était l'échec permanent
les dirigeants communistes sont des
destructeurs répondu monsieur mitterrand
sur tf1
ils veulent la politique de la terre
brûlée et puis il ya le sort des petites
listes ou plutôt des listes qui ne sont
pas représentés au parlement
tout vous le savez protestent contre le
mode de scrutin qui comme le dit
philippe le breton l'un des dirigeants
d'europe écologie conduit au système du
parti unique et certaines d'entre elles
se voient condamnés m pas présenté ce
fut le cas aujourd'hui de la démocratie
chrétienne française et aussi des de
l'union des français pour leur droite
des patries c'est à dire la liste qui
avait réussi à réconcilier le temps
d'une campagne de jean-louis
tixier-vignancour et jean marie le pen
leur tête de liste
l'écrivain michel de saint pierre a
annoncé tout à l'heure la mort dans
l'âme qu'il renonçait nous renonçons à
nos enfants parce que les conditions
qu'on nous fait ne sont pas
démocratiques je pense que vous savez
que nous ne sommes pas en démocratie
en tout cas je vous lire la déclaration
de l'avons fait à la presse tout à
l'heure michel de saint pierre jean
louis tixier vignancour jean marie le
pen tête de liste de l'union française
pour l'euro droite des patries eut fait
n'ayant pu réunir le milliards d'anciens
francs exigés pratiquement par les
auteurs de la loi 5 millions pour les
frais d'impression 5 millions pour les
frais d'affichage les gours il condamne
un système qui interdit aux familles
politiques et spirituels minoritaire de
s'exprimer dans les élections privant
ainsi plusieurs millions de citoyens de
pignons dit versant de toute
représentation
tout a été fait pour que les listes
minoritaires ne puisse pas défendre leur
chance
encore une fois nous ne sommes pas dans
la démocratie française nous sommes sous
l' empire d'une espèce de dictature
sournoise et feutrée et n'acceptons pas
cela voilà pour les déclarations europe
toujours avec la suite de notre lexique
notre abécédaire des institutions ce
soir nous nous arrêtons à la lettre t t
comme traité de rome c'est une synthèse
de jean-michel mercurol mars 1957
si gouvernement signe tarom l'acte de
naissance de la communauté économique
européenne le traité de rome c'est
l'aboutissement du programme schumann
2950 créé avant tout la solidarité
européenne par des réalisations
concrètes
à commencer par la communauté charbon
acier qui mettent en commun les
ressources de base des six pays
le premier lingot européen écoulée les
premiers trains de minerais traverse les
frontières
l'idée de l'europe viennent passer à la
réalité de gasperi l'italien adenauer
l'allemand robert schuman et jean monnet
les français quatre hommes qui ont porté
cette europe sur les fonts baptismaux
l'union douanière les politiques
économiques communes telles seront en
1957 les objectifs du traité de rome
avec le marché commun les personnes les
services les biens les capitaux vont
pouvoir circuler librement
le volume des échanges se multiplient et
l'europe verte prend son essor dans la
vitrine de l'europe s'amoncellent alors
les produits du marché commun désormais
chaque denrée proposé à la ménagère way
son prix dépendre largement des
règlements communautaires
enfin l'europe parvient jusqu'aux porte
monnaie des européens en 72 le succès du
marché commun ainsi trois autres pays à
ratifier à leur tour le traité de rome
l'angleterre l'irlande et le danemark
entre dans l'europe
la communauté des filles est devenue
l'europe des neuf alors toujours dans le
cadre de nos explications sur le fond
des choses c'est gai et tout à l'heure
un rendez-vous avec le second volet
cette semaine de spécial élections
européennes une émission vous le savez
parrainé conjointement par europe 1 et
antennes de l'émission qui permet
d'interroger les leaders sur le fond
sans sacrifier au spectaculaire sur le
studio bernard cadinot que nous
rejoignons cette émission spéciale
europe organisé à la fois par antenne 2
et europe 1 va commencer tout de suite
après le journal les invités en sont ce
soir est successivement monsieur jacques
chirac pour le rpr et monsieur georges
marchais pour le parti communiste
monsieur chirac sera interrogé pendant
une quarantaine de minutes par noël
copain gérard carreyrou patrick poivre
d'arvor qui aura tout juste le temps de
quitter le studio de journal pour le
studio voisin et etienne mougeotte qui
dirigera le débat monsieur georges
marchais de son côté répondre
aux questions de catherine nay jean
pierre jaulin alain duhamel débat dirigé
par jean pierre elkabbach avec une
petite particularité monsieur jacques
chirac sera ce soir ici à paris tandis
que monsieur marchait et les
journalistes qui vont l'interroger sont
installés dans un studio à strasbourg
puisque monsieur marchette doit tenir
une réunion dans cette ville après notre
émission spéciale europe antenne d
europe 1 monsieur chirac
monsieur marchait dans quelques minutes
type la radioscopie des fédérations
indiscutablement les fédérations de
parents d'élèves joue un rôle de premier
plan dans le système éducatif
elle possède des pouvoirs étendus et
participe à toutes les instances
administratives ou presque de
l'enseignement dans le primaire où les
parents élus siègent aux côtés des
instituteurs dans les conseils d'école
dans le secondaire au conseil
d'établissement où il participe à la
bonne marche du lycée ou du collège aux
conseils de classe et dans les
commissions d'orientation devant
lesquelles les familles peuvent faire
appel à la suite de l'orientation de
leurs enfants
enfin les fédérations sont également
habilité à représenter collectivement
les parents auprès des pouvoirs publics
bref la participation se traduit
aujourd'hui par la présence des parents
à tous les échelons de la vie scolaire
on ne peut pas séparer ce qui se passe à
la maison est ce qui se passe à l'école
il y a un rôle éducatif et tous les
éducateurs que ce soit les parents les
enseignants doivent coopérer ensemble ou
si on est au début la participation je
crois que les enseignants doivent avoir
conscience que leur rôle est essentiel à
l'école mais qu'il aura d'autant plus de
qualité qu'ils feront participer les
parents à leur juste place dans
l'enseignement public quatre fédérations
défendent les intérêts des élèves deux
fédérations modeste la fnape est surtout
bien introduites dans l'enseignement
technologique et l'unap plus connu sous
le nom de fédération autonome né en 1968
en réaction aux événements de mai et qui
mènent une lutte farouche contre la
politisation à l'école mais en fait deux
fédérations se partagent la majorité des
suffrages des parents d'élèves
la fcpe ou fédérations cornec du nom de
son président en place depuis 1956 et
l'apep animée par le dr lagarde dont le
60e congrès s'ouvre demain matin dijon
devant quelques 900 délits qu il y a une
notion qui se fait jour c'est que les
jeunes parents ont une exigence beaucoup
plus grande dans cette concertation ils
veulent des résultats rapides ils
n'accepteront pas et ils auront raison
d'être manipulé choix par des syndicats
d'enseignants soit par l'administration
le fédération aux sensibilités bien
différente
la pep longtemps considéré comme proche
du ministère manifestent depuis
l'arrivée en 1973 d'antoine lagarde
une réelle indépendance et le ménage
guère ses critiques par exemple devant
l'insuffisance du sport à l'école
la fédération cornec regroupe
principalement les parents qui ont comme
on dit le coeur à gauche ce qui lui vaut
bien souvent d'être taxé de fédération
politique je dis que si c'est affirmer
que nous sommes à la remarque d'un parti
politique c'est absolument faux mais si
ce pour reconnaître que sur la politique
scolaire du gouvernement nous avons le
droit de porter jugement est d'essayer
de la faire infléchir si elle est
mauvaise alors la pièce sûrs que nous
faisons la politique presse que ces deux
fédérations par leur puissance
représentent de véritables moyens de
pression dans le système éducatif
deux exemples le dossier scolaire
farouchement combattue par la fédération
cornec a finalement été supprimée
d'autre part l'intense campagne menée
par la fédération lagarde a obligé les
pouvoirs publics à accélérer la
modification des rythmes scolaires
ces rythmes scolaires qui seront avec
l'amélioration du sport à l'école
les grands thèmes du congrès de la
fédération la gare a dit jean donc à
partir de demain sport cyclisme
maintenant avec la course du dauphiné
libéré aujourd'hui deuxième étape
roanne villeurbanne la victoire est
revenue vous allez voir hollandais et
pira qui prend la deuxième place au
classement général derrière l'allemand
pas l'heure voici donc le hollandais
espira arrivant à villeurbanne
quelques chiffres maintenant avant le
bulletin de la météo d'abord les
pronostics de pierre de bresse pour la
course du tiercé qui se disputera demain
à longchamp alors elle a choisi lé 18 le
11 le 5 le 19 le 2 le 10 et le 6 je
pense que vous avez eu le temps de noter
18 11 5 19 de 10 6 il y avait aussi le
loto sont sortis cette fois les six
numéros suivants le cincle 11 le 34e 36e
42e et le 48 comme numéro complémentaire
le dise voilà j'espère que vous ne
mélangez pas et que vous ne jouerez pas
le 48 demain pour le tiercé la météo
maintenant aujourd'hui poursuite du
temps médiocre sur l'ensemble du pays
avec en particulier des pluies éparses
quelques belles éclaircies sur le
nord-ouest pour demain et bien même type
de temps à variable louvoyer avec des
ondées arrivé en fin de journée sur
l'ouest du pays de nombreux nuages
porteurs hélas de pluie les jours
suivants le temps pluvieux devrait pas
assister jusqu'au début de la semaine
prochaine avec toujours l'alternance de
zone nuageuse et d'éclaircies ces
dernières surtout sur le midi voilà deux
rendez vous avec l'information sur
antenne 2 ce soir le premier dans
quelques minutes on vous l'a déjà dit
spécial élections européennes avec ce
soir jacques chirac et georges marchais
je vous quitte d'ailleurs pourquoi les
studios et puis en fin de soirée vers
23h10 vous retrouverez pierre-alain pour
le dernier journal
quant à moi eh bien je prends congé de
vous et je vous retrouverai lundi en
direct d'athènes pour la signature de
l'entrée de la grèce dans le marché
commun et c'est léon zitrone qui prendra
mon lait durant ces quatre shows bonne
fin de semaine à ceux qui ont la chance
de partir bonne soirée à tous et à
bientôt